[Music]
crack the window if you don't open the
put door your phone
with your right hand open the door
now
with the right hand open the door open
the door
open the door
get your arm out get your arm out get
your arm out now
go
drop the gun
shut up
[Applause]
all right come on it's okay it's okay
[Music]
let's take them inside yeah
okay here let's go in here okay you okay
got the car
now the car let me see your hands
open your window open the door
open the door
okay
open the door real slow
okay put down your phone
put down your phone
with your right hand open the door
with your right hand open the door open
the door
open your door
come on out
come on now hold on i got my hold on
step out get out of the car
yes
i guess
i was the kid
and he's the one our freaking heads were
all right there
i mean had it been lower
i was pulling in i fucking heard that
and i was like what was that
you guys good though yeah we're good
if you want to get a witness statement
take it into the witness of the
drive-thru who saw the gun pulled okay
[Music]
our heads were right here that's where
the bullet hit
oh these shots that well there's a kid
in the back seat
blue blue gotcha kids are in the car
kids are in the car hold out the gun
where's he hit nobody's hit nobody's hit
all right
flip him
flip them
so what little little boy pulls out a
gun i look back and there's a
this lock hey ruby let's take this
inside the outside good fuck i flip it
around come back on this side
what's the start
hey guys you with this car no
keep going all right keep going
who's fucking
okay
was the kid aiming for you guys yes i
come here
there's a window i come walking up to
look in and all of a sudden this silver
handgun comes out like this i'm like
oh you pushed it i pushed it as they
fired
and it went over these guys his head
that's the only one i have okay
um who was the individual who saw the
firearm
and do you guys have security cameras we
do but we don't have access to them
until four o'clock oh actually no not
until tomorrow tomorrow okay uh two four
four i thought it was two houses how did
you have surprised me today okay yeah so
four o'clock okay so what i'm gonna have
are you thinking
you're fine take your time
you did okay
okay guys so where's the kids
there's another opposite
perfect so i'm to have you guys fill
this information out with your
information
and then just explain in detail what
occurred right who would the individual
what or
you know what does he look like
what he did
what you guys did and it can be as long
as short as possible once you guys are
done find one of us
um
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]